si è abituati a pensare all'abuso di
cibo soltanto in termini di obesità
quando le mangiamo troppo invece il
problema oggi è l'abuso di informazione
usiamo male le informazioni circa il
cibo e quindi ci perdiamo la magia e
smettiamo di pensare di immaginare che
possiamo essere dei veri maghi
come possiamo immaginare che il cibo
funzioni sembra banale eppure no non ci
accorgiamo che quando mangiamo quello
che mangiamo nel nostro corpo si
comporta proprio come un cartone animato
entra e fa un effetto la funzione del
cibo del nostro corpo non è così banale
perché istantaneamente cambia modifica
il funzionamento di ogni cellule dei
nostri organi che cosa significa questo
significa che possiamo essere in grado
ad ogni pasto di generare innescare una
reazione che possa essere verso la
salute verso la malattia
oggi il killer vero si chiama sindrome
metabolica
la sindrome tra pollica è quella che poi
chiamata la madre dei killers che sono
le malattie cardiovascolari diabete il
cancro l'alzheimer il parkinson e tante
altre croniche degenerative bene questa
sindrome è legata a un grasso che si
chiama grasso viscerale
voi potete pungere la vostra pancia e
prendere del grasso che è sottocutaneo
non vi piace
eppure il grasso viscerale e dentro non
lo vedete
ma pensate che un grasso viscerale che
pesa veramente poco e in grado di
produrre tre volte le molecole le
sostanze pro infiammatori del la stessa
quantità di grasso sottocutaneo quindi
oggi ci dobbiamo preoccupare di quello
che ci accade dentro e quello che ci
accade dentro dipende da quello che
mettiamo nel nostro piatto
poi dipende dalla mia
niente dipende dalla nostra genetica
eppure abbiamo in mano uno strumento
fondamentale il cibo il cibo che
funziona in base a come lo scegliamo lo
prepariamo lo associamo e lo mettiamo
nel piatto
quando si parla di nutrizione funzionale
stiamo considerando proprio questo
dobbiamo imparare a capire chi siamo e
costruire un abito su misura attraverso
la scelta del cibo che possiamo mettere
nel nostro piatto
questo è il cuore il progetto ormonale
ogni pasto è un progetto ormonale un
progetto ormonale che significa un
network di ormone che istantaneamente i
nostri organi liberano quindi lasciamo
da parte le mode alimentari i metodi
alimentari
immaginiamo invece di compiere la magia
non serve scegliere il cibo ottimale
cibo perfetto il cibo super smart si poi
esistono anche dei cibi che io chiamo
amici dei cibi buoni che siano in grado
di per esempio gestire la fame perché la
fame in sintomo la fanno il sintomo di
squilibrio ormonale
se questi cibi sono in grado di per
esempio tenere bassa l'insulina che è
uno degli ormoni principi causa della
deposizione di grasso viscerale e quindi
della sindrome metabolica
ma quello che è importante è pensare in
unico in sinergia
costruiamo un pasto perché non mangiamo
cibi ma che mangiamo un mix di cibi
appunto un pasto una ricetta la pasta al
pomodoro non è un alimento è un mix di
alimenti cucinati in un certo modo e
proposte al nostro corpo in un certo
modo
eppure si poi dicevo esistono degli
alimenti speciali quindi lotti non si
compie quando utilizziamo degli alimenti
pe speciali magnifici eccezionali ma li
mescoli ameri combiniamo insieme quindi
in questa combinazione di cibi
realizziamo quel progetto ormonali
il progetto monale essenziale quando si
parla di nutrizione funzionale si sta
immaginando una tipo di alimentazione
che controlla il
infiammazione silente è un processo
infiammatorio contino che nel nostro
corpo si innesca e non finisce mai e
costantemente ogni giorno invecchiamo ci
ammaliamo io dico sempre tutti noi
dobbiamo guarire da quando nasciamo
dobbiamo guarire non esiste la
prevenzione primaria perché comunque
cominciano a sbagliare qualcosa volenti
o nolenti l'ambiente dicevo i geni
quello che mangiamo e dobbiamo iniziare
il processo di guarigione
lo possiamo fare soltanto se impariamo a
gestire i nostri piatti
ogni giorno ogni pasto che non gestire
un occasione mancata per guadagnare
salute essere al cento per cento il
meglio di voi stessi
l'infiammazione cosiddetta silente e
un'infiammazione che produce sostanze
tossiche che si chiamano per esempio
radicali liberi infiammazione si produce
se mangiamo male se produciamo ormoni
tipo l'insulina ma anche per esempio se
la flora batterica o meglio il
microbioma intestinale produce dei
metaboliti che non sono utili liri
assorbiamo bene anche qui reagisce
l'alimentazione quello che mangiamo in
grado di gestire tutti quelli batteri
virus funghi ed altro che vive dentro di
noi e king con noi e in simbiosi per la
nostra salute
quanti supplementi assumete ogni giorno
sperando nella muleto magico e invece il
vostro moleto e nel piatto il microbiota
intestinale anch'esso gestisce questa
infiammazione migrazione silente oggi
che si parla tanto di longevità è
proprio questo ogni volta che noi
scateniamo un processo infiammatorio
abbiamo bisogno di riparare ogni
processo riparativo consuma il
potenziale di longevità che è scritto
nei telomeri la parte terminale del
cromosoma che ogni volta che ripariamo
si accorcia di una sequenza più si
accorcia più la cellula alla fine non si
riproduce è un po come giocare un video
games consumate le vostre vite più siete
infiammati più vite consumate e quindi
la longevità anche dipende da quello che
mettete nel piatto
oggi si parla molto di digiuno non c'è
bisogno di digiunare c'è bisogno di
imparare la strategia alla base mimare
il digiuno attraverso quei cibi amici di
cui ho parlato
che cos'è il digiuno per esempio un
equilibrio ormonale che ci consente di
vivere a lungo e bene bene possiamo
raggiungerlo mimando il digiuno coi cibi
che mettiamo nel piatto
uno tra tutti il controllo attraverso il
mix di cibi giusti e attraverso
l'utilizzo di strategie di preparazione
del cibo ottimali
il controllo del cosiddetto indice
insulinico magari a cui i due hanno
sentito parlare di indice glicemico
carico glicemico
lasciate perdere pensate piuttosto in
modo ormonale pensare in modo funzionale
significa proprio questo significa
pensare all'azione funzionale del cibo
nel vostro corpo
nel momento in cui parlate di funzioni
state parlando di organi fegato rene
pancreas surrene tiroide
pensate un po nel vostro piatto
finiscono degli alimenti che sono in
grado che istantaneamente di
condizionare il lavoro dei vostri organi
è entusiasmante questo ecco la magia del
cibo è proprio questa
quella di essere in grado ad ogni pasto
di ricondizionare nuovamente riscrivere
un nuovo programma e quindi anche a
questa legata alla longevità non serve
fare anti aging non serve mangiare
l'alimento magico che ci mantiene in
salute
l'importanza per esempio diceva è quella
del controllo insulinico questo ormone
che istantaneamente ogni giorno finisce
in maniera troppo eccessiva essere
prodotto perché i nostri pasti non sono
combinati bene insieme che mangia
insieme un piatto di riso lamela cibo
perfetto cibo sano invece no perché
scatena troppo insulina libera troppo
insulina allora è sbagliata la mela
forse è sbagliato il riso no
probabilmente non conosciamo quello che
accade quando questi alimenti incontrano
i nostri
in questo caso inoltre nostre cellule e
quindi come le nostre cellule poi
reagiscono e quindi come nostri organi
producono
gli ormoni che sono i messaggeri che li
mettono in contatto quindi non basta
conoscere il cibo nutrizione funzionale
significa a partire da chi siamo
da come funzioniamo e quindi da come il
cibo riesce a cambiare le nostre
funzioni organiche che significa codice
della vita
questo significa aggiungere è vero più
vita giorni e più giorni alla vita
vivere meglio oggi ma per vivere più a
lungo e questo a cui dovrebbe tendere
ogni obiettivo medico e non medico a
volte si pensa troppo in breve
soprattutto nel mondo nostro della
medicina
facciamo tutto quello che è possibile
fare nell'immediato risolviamo un
sintomo curiamo non guariamo attraverso
la nutrizione funzionale possiamo
guarire perché siamo in grado di
combinare in uno stesso pasto gli
alimenti che siano in grado
ricordate di condizionare il lavoro
degli organi e quindi l'equilibrio
ormonale e quindi l'infiammazione e
quindi di metterci nelle condizioni di
vivere meglio oggi ripeto e vivere
meglio domani
in una parola questo è il codice della
vita grazie